normal counting dollars we'll be
counting stars okay first of all Shawn
Mendes was the absolute cutest but
apparently everything wasn't so cute
back then which we know thanks to an
inspirational message he posted for fans
opening up about his early YouTube days
[Music]
Shawn took the Instagram penning this
lengthy caption which in part says quote
I'm thinking about being in 9th grade
right now
the day after I posted one of my first
covers onto YouTube back in 2014 at
school walking down the hall straight
into a group of older guys yelling out
sing for me Shawn sing for me in a way
that made me feel absolutely horrible
made me feel like a joke like what I was
doing was just stupid and wrong okay can
I just say that I hope those guys feel
pretty lame now like imagine making fun
of Shawn Mendes or anyone for that
matter not cool and he really was good
back then shawn continues on saying he
was lucky to have had the best friends
and parents ever and added quote it's
not a joke to me to make someone feel
bad about doing what they love every
single person deserves to do what makes
them feel alive shawn says he hopes that
no matter how old you are
you deserve to follow your heart and
that he's rooting for you seriously he's
the best I've grown up and kind of just
become a lot more just cool and happy
with being in my body and myself and
what I'm talking about and you know I'm
not I'm not as worried about what people
think as much tons of his famous pals
commented on the post
niall horan wrote couldn't relate or
agree with something more if I tried we
had the last laugh Benny Blanco Hayley
kiyoko Lauren her eggy and david dobrik
also showed Shawn some love and kamila
Kibeho simply wrote this is beautiful
you know what else is beautiful that
seniorita video which I'm still not
/ and also how Sean has always been this
open anxiety is not a myth and everybody
has their own version of it and their
own reasons for having it and I put my
story out there and I hope people can
kind of connect with it and use it for
them and I think that's why it's
connecting on mendes everybody anyways
let me know what you think of Shawn's
post maybe why you love him so much and
for all the latest on him keep it locked
to all things et until next time I'm
Katie Krause and bye for now